Traduttore: Robert Tucker
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Vi parlo di una cosa molto semplice,
che ci riguarda tutti,
che come usiamo le parole.
È un po' la mia fissazione
nel senso che io passo la vita
a parlare di parole
e a cercare di usarle bene.
E prima di tutto, ho provato
queste cose su di me.
La prima cosa che vi voglio dire è questa.
Non ci riflettiamo mai abbastanza,
ma il linguaggio è la cosa
che ci rende umani.
Noi siamo gli unici animali
che hanno il potere della parola.
Pensate agli animali che avete in casa,
un gatto, un cane.
Sapete bene che il gatto
non dice solo: "Miao",
il cane non dice solo: "Bau";
ma il gatto dice
un sacco di "miao" diversi,
il cane un sacco di "bau" diversi,
eppure, nessun animale,
per quanto intelligente,
riesce usare uno strumento sofisticato
come il linguaggio umano.
Il Professor Chomsky,
in un intervista molto buffa,
rilasciata a Ali G, che è il rapper
inventato da Sacha Baron Cohen,
risponde così alla domanda
che gli fa il rapper che è:
"Professore, ma lei che è 80 anni
che si occupa di lingua,
non si è stancato sempre di parlare
di lingua o del linguaggio?"
E lui risponde così: "No, in realtà no,
perché la lingua
è la caratteristica nucleare
che ci rende esseri umani.
Noi non possiamo fare a meno delle parole,
eppure, siccome la lingua madre
ce l'abbiamo da sempre,
praticamente gratis da quando nasciamo,
non ci pensiamo mai abbastanza.
Eppure, ogni parola che noi scegliamo
ha un sacco di usi,
serve a un sacco di cose.
La prima cosa che noi facciamo
con la lingua è questa:
descriviamo la realtà che ci circonda.
Pensate bene, noi parliamo della realtà
e decodifichiamo la realtà,
mettendole dei cartellini,
e ci riusciamo a intendere, perché
siamo d'accordo su questi cartellini.
Potrei citare un famoso sketch
di Aldo, Giovanni e Giacomo,
che forse conoscete,
è quello della cadrega,
carega per chi è veneto;
come funziona lì: che due persone
mettono alla prova un'altra
per capire se fanno parte
della stessa "tribù",
perché non c'è accordo
sul significato della parola "cadrega".
Infatti, Aldo prende una mela,
e dice: "Buona questa cadrega"
e gli altri capiscono che lui è un estraneo.
Quindi, a noi, serve la lingua
per descrivere ciò che ci circonda.
Vi faccio notare un'altra cosa.
Siccome la realtà cambia di continuo,
è in evoluzione perenne,
allora, anche la lingua
cambia di continuo.
Non è detto che questo ci piaccia,
ma su questo torniamo fra un attimo.
La lingua ci serve per comunicare,
ovviamente, fra di noi,
e come vi dicevo prima,
oltre che comunicare e basta,
la lingua definisce la mia tribù.
Quindi, io identifico le persone
che appartengono alla mia stessa tribù.
Noi pensiamo di essere andati avanti
rispetto al concetto tribale,
ma così non è,
siamo ancora estremamente tribali
come esseri umani,
e allo stesso tempo identifico le persone
che non fanno parte della mia tribù.
Quindi mi permette
di individuare "gli altri".
Pensate allo sketch
che vi ho raccontato prima.
La lingua serve per una terza
cosa molto importante,
che forse è quella
che ci interessa di più.
Ogni parola che usiamo
è letteralmente un atto di identità.
Cioè io dico agli altri chi sono,
faccio una dichiarazione.
Quand'è che ci si innamora
veramente di una persona,
ci si può invaghire dell'aspetto fisico,
ma la cosa veramente che ci colpisce
sono le cose che dice
e in che modo dice quelle cose.
Ovviamente, essendo il linguaggio
la proprietà nucleare delle persone,
noi ci innamoriamo di questo,
cioè della parte
più profonda della persona.
Infatti, spesso
ci si innamora che di brutti,
perché non è così importante.
L'importante alla fine è quello che dice.
Poi a che altro serve la lingua.
Ovviamente, se io racconto
delle cose di me,
quelle parole, le devo pensare bene,
perché che cosa voglio
che gli altri capiscano di me?
Ve lo chiedete mai quando, per esempio,
rilasciato un pezzettino di frase
su Facebook, in pubblico,
che cosa penseranno gli altri di me
leggendo quella cosa che ho scritto.
Poi magari, me ne pento
e voglio cancellare,
ma, come sapete tutti,
esiste dio screenshot,
e quindi anche cancellare
è un po' un'utopia.
Dice Searle: "Non è possibile
pensare con chiarezza
se non si è capaci di parlare
e scrivere con chiarezza."
Cioè il nostro modo di comunicare
spiega anche agli altri
quanto è chiaro il nostro pensiero,
quanto siamo in grado
di concepire un pensiero lineare,
perché se il pensiero è lineare,
allora siamo anche in grado
di veicolarlo in maniera lineare.
Un po' quello che diceva
Nanni Moretti, ve lo ricordate?
Siamo sempre quel campo lì.
Ovviamente, le lingue, tutte,
hanno molte più parole
di quelle strettamente necessarie.
Facciamo un attimo di statistica.
L'italiano ha dalle 300 mila
al milione di parole.
È difficile fare una stima precisa
perché dipende da quali parti,
per esempio, dei dialetti,
consideriamo parte anche
del lessico italiano.
Una persona mediamente colta,
diciamo alla fine degli studi superiori,
conosce circa 35-40 mila parole,
Ma non le usiamo tutte.
Noi, nelle nostre attività quotidiane,
ce la caviamo con circa due mila parole.
Molte di più sono quelle che sentiamo,
e quindi conosciamo perché,
per esempio, i media le usano spesso.
Non lo so: "penitenziario",
"meteorologico", e via dicendo.
Abbiamo un patrimonio
sterminato di parole,
e, secondo me, più o meno tutti
intuiamo abbastanza chiaramente
che le parole non sono tutte uguali.
Una parola può essere un bacio,
una parola può essere un proiettile.
Allora, il modo più facile
di identificare le parole
è fare una lista di quelle brutte.
Pensate che è quello
che si fa spesso online.
Io mi faccio una blacklist di parolacce.
E quindi, se una persona
usa quelle parolacce,
io non pubblico il post.
Quel post viene censurato.
Ma è sempre così?
Pensate una parola come "negro".
Tutti quanti rabbrividiscono.
Se la dice un bianco in senso offensivo
nei confronti di un afroamericano,
è chiaro che è una parola brutta.
Ma avete notato che, per esempio,
i rapper afroamericani
le usano nei loro testi per autodefinirsi,
perché è un modo
di sottolineare black power.
Quindi neanche una parola "brutta",
come "negro",
può essere stigmatizzata a priori,
In realtà, dipende dal contesto
in cui quella parola viene usata.
Ma facciamo qualche esempio
più vicino a noi.
Potrebbe essere un ortaggio "finocchio",
oppure un modo molto maleducato
di riferirsi al omosessuale.
Usiamo una frase:
Entro in una mensa e dico,
"Oh, oggi a pranzo ci sono i finocchi."
Mi sto riferendo al piatto
che probabilmente molti di voi amano.
Finocchi fanno bene, drenanti.
Entro nella stessa mensa,
c'è un tavolo di attivisti LGBT,
"Uh, oggi a pranzo ci sono i finocchi."
Stessa frase.
Ma cosa cambia?
L'intento comunicativo.
Che faccio? Flaggo a priori
la parola "finocchio" perché è negativa?
No, perché a questo punto
dovrei censurare metà del mio lessico.
Cagna.
"Cagna", nel corso degli anni,
da cane femmina,
ha assunto un altro significato,
che forse vi ricordate,
perché è diventato famoso
anche grazie alla serie televisiva,
quello prima di "attrice scadente",
e poi, appunto, usato in senso negativo
nei confronti delle donne.
Talmente questa parola
ha assunto un significato negativo,
che i padroni di cani femmine
preferiscono fare delle circonlocuzioni.
Non dicono: "Porto fuori la cagna."
Sennò qualcuno potrebbe
pensare alla moglie. No?
Ma piuttosto dicono "la canetta",
"la canina", "la cana". Ah!?
Ci autocensuriamo, perché, sennò,
uno potrebbe pensare male.
Vi stupisco colla terza parola: "signora".
Come "signora" negativo?
Allora, se ne parlo coi ragazzi,
i ragazzi mi dicono:
"Sì, signora è negativo
nel senso che magari una è giovane,
sarebbe una signorina, allora,
chiamata signora si offende."
Ma è molto più sottile
quello che vi faccio notare.
A me, è successo diverse volte.
Unica donna in stanza di uomini.
Tutti i professionisti.
L'uomo che entra nella sala chiama
"dottori" i maschi e "signora" la donna.
Al che, io di solito
reagisco piuttosto male,
quindi, per fino una parola che in realtà,
voglio dire, è positiva come signora,
se usata in un certo senso,
potrebbe diventare,
non dico offensiva, ma comunque,
perlomeno, dare fastidio a qualcuno.
Allora, capite
che non basta la lista nera.
Non basta la lista nera,
non basta la censura.
Ma ci vuole una cosa fondamentale
che è la nostra intelligenza.
Dobbiamo pensarci noi, anche perché
le parole non sono solo parole.
Pensate a un'altra cosa
che fanno le parole.
Le parole compiono azioni.
Se io sono un professore,
ho il potere di promuovere
o bocciare uno studente.
Se io sono un sindaco,
ho il potere di sposare le persone.
Se io sono un medico,
ho il potere di dichiarare
la nascita e la morte.
Avete presente nei medical drama
la persona non è morta
finché una persona,
un'altra persona nel ruolo giusto,
non ha dichiarato il decesso.
Cioè noi compiamo atti con le parole.
Compiamo atti di continuo.
Pensate all'atto supremo: giurare.
Giurare una cosa serissima.
Ma ha delle conseguenze
pratiche se io spergiuro?
In realtà, no.
Ma fra le persone
c'è una c'è una specie di patto,
per cui, se io giuro,
penso veramente a quella cosa lì.
Non giuro con leggerezza,
anche se in realtà sappiamo tutti
che nessuno ci fulminerà.
Questo è il potere della parola.
Allora, in un mondo
così sovraccarico di parole,
perché è vero che è sovraccarico,
siamo circondati continuamente da parole,
io vi invito a fare una cosa:
riprendiamoci il potere
della parola giusta.
Questa è una cosa che possiamo fare tutti.
Perché non implica imparare cose strane.
Implica a prendere in mano
una competenza che abbiamo tutti,
che è quella della parola,
e usarla meglio.
Vi do tre consigli in questo senso.
La prima: coltivare il dubbio.
Noi viviamo in un'era che, a causa
della quantità di informazioni presenti,
ci dà l'illusione della conoscenza.
Ovviamente, conoscere non è googlare.
Conoscere è qualcosa
di molto più approfondito.
Allora, noi, giorno dopo giorno,
in qualsiasi settore della conoscenza,
dobbiamo chiederci
i limiti delle cose che sappiamo.
Quanto poco so.
Quanto poco so di tutta l'immensità
di informazioni che mi circonda.
E questo vale anche per la lingua.
Ogni giorno, se conosco
35.000 parole su un milione,
è normale che io ogni giorno possa
incontrare parole che non conosco.
Allora, davanti a quelle parole,
io avrò un sensazione di fastidio
perché io voglio certezze nella vita.
Gli esseri umani vogliono certezze.
I cambiamenti, le cose che non conosciamo,
ci spaventano.
Però, almeno in campo linguistico,
è facile risolvere il problema:
vado su un vocabolario.
Ma oggi è ancora più facile:
posso googlare.
Ma alla fine la cosa è la stessa, cioè:
incontro una parola che non conosco,
vi faccio un esempio
dal gennaio di quest'anno: "gelicidio".
"Gelicidio" ha creato
un sacco di scontento.
Molti hanno pensato che fosse
una parola nuova, un neologismo.
È una parola del 1360,
quindi ha 700 anni.
E allora, come mai non la conoscevo?
Perché ognuno di noi conosce
solo una piccola parte
di tutto il lessico
che abbiamo a disposizione.
Quindi, la prima cosa
è il dubbio che è fecondo,
perché l'unico modo
di aumentare la conoscenza
è sapere di non sapere.
Nel momento in cui siamo convinti
di sapere tutto quello che ci serve,
la nostra capacità di imparare
cose nuove si atrofizza.
Prima cosa.
Seconda.
Possiamo riflettere
il tempo di un respiro.
In realtà, è semplicissimo. Perché?
Perché ne abbiamo la facoltà.
Abbiamo un po' l'illusione
di doverci muovere sempre,
di essere sempre di corsa,
di non avere il tempo
di pensare alle cose.
Ma non è vero.
Anche quando abbiamo voglia
di fare un post su Facebook,
per fare un esempio,
possiamo sempre fermarci 10 secondi
a pensare a quello
che vogliamo veramente dire.
Riprendiamoci il lusso di riflettere
su quello che stiamo per immettere,
indiciamo al mondo che ci circonda,
quella microparticella d'informazione,
pensiamoci un attimo di più.
Non è difficile.
E poi un terzo consiglio,
altrettanto semplice.
Quando non siamo competenti,
e non sappiamo le cose,
cose che succede molto spesso,
possiamo sempre scegliere il silenzio.
Noi viviamo nella società
che è abituata a polarizzarsi su tutto.
E invece, a volte,
si può scegliere di non dire nulla.
Anche perché, se io dico
le cose sbagliate,
occorre che ci ricordiamo
che le cose che abbiamo digitato
soprattutto rimangano.
Ci rimangono attaccate,
e contribuiranno alla creazione
della nostra personalità online.
Vogliamo veramente dire questa cosa
che poi rimane lì, attaccata a noi,
come una specie di cartaccia
che abbiamo immesso nel mondo?
Quindi, come vedete,
le cose sono semplici:
dubbio, riflessione, silenzio.
Alla fine è buffo,
perché in qualche modo sono tre richieste
che non riguardano direttamente la lingua,
ma delle quali la lingua
è una conseguenza.
Alla fine di tutto questo,
vorrei farvi notare una cosa.
Queste competenze non sono immediate.
Occorre lavorarci tanto.
È quello che io chiamo
"bisogna essere contadini della lingua".
Perché, che cosa fanno i contadini?
Forse, voi l'avete presente:
i contadini si impegnano
giorno dopo giorno,
non si stancano mai,
sanno che dal momento
in cui dissodano il campo
al momento in cui cresce la piantina,
passa molto tempo,
passa un sacco di tempo,
bisogna proprio che si impegnino tanto.
Allora, l'ho riassunta così:
la conseguenza di fatica, sudore,
costanza, resilienza e anche fiducia in sé
è questa piantina qui,
che alla fine ha bucato anche l'asfalto.
Non occorre per forza essere delle spugne,
magari siamo più simili all'asfalto,
ma la conoscenza è ancora
più resiliente di noi,
e se diamo una chance,
potrebbe andare a finire così.
Grazie.
(Applausi)